[Applause]
dear Matt keep playing those schoolyard
games I know that they are the best part
of your day and you might not yet know
they are also important to your future
those games you play with MO and the
rest of the boys are laying a foundation
for your future as a member and leader
of teams and the games you play when
they have all gone home and you are
alone with the ball and the hoop those
are equal in their fundamental value
when you envision yourself in
championship moments counting down the
seconds in your head driving past
invisible defenders you are giving
yourself a destination
[Music]
they're all be stops along the way that
you could not possibly imagine
did you know mitt that you will be the
first in your family to go to college
did you know that your father the
elevator operator and your mother with
the 8th grade education who cleans
office floors at night those children of
Polish immigrants did you know that they
are doing those things to ensure
opportunities for you and your brother
you will become a cadet and a basketball
player at one of the greatest
institutions for leadership in the world
their encouragement will send you to
West Point and when you grow up when you
become a head coach first an army and
then it do when you find yourself
coaching a team and championship moments
what sit up you'll feel as if you've
been there before
[Music]
because of what you are doing right now
in that schoolyard in inner-city Chicago
you will know what to do
never underestimate the immense power of
your imagination you will use it all
your life there will be a time in your
future
when you are approaching 50 years old
when you will become disconnected with
those things you learned in the school
yard where it wasn't always about
winning and when the experience and the
feeling were what mattered most the
pressure will become heavy and you will
feel that burden in your body as well as
in your mind one of the missing sparks
tonight is new coach Mike chef ski still
suffering the video effects your family
will ask you to take a step away from
the team and the game you love it will
be hard but please listen to them and
let them help you reclaim the part of
yourself that finds joy and meaning in
the process and that understands the
importance of balance and their take it
easy on your mom okay it won't be long
before you realize that she is your
first hero your passion for creating
opportunities for the next generation
begins with her as does your sense of
humor
watch her listen to her she is selfless
and courageous
[Applause]
for whatever reason life will be good to
you it will offer you many opportunities
and you will do your best to make the
most of them your ability to seize those
opportunities licen what you're doing
right now and the people you have around
you please pay attention you'll be
talking about that schoolyard a half
century from now you will still be able
to feel the pavement beneath your feet
and experience the joy of the countless
celebrations of imagined victories good
job today you will tell stories of your
mother's courage to Walker rooms full of
athletes and gymnasiums full of hopeful
high school graduates you're not going
to believe how lucky you are
Coach K